mr. Wain Wade from the Chicago Bulls who
joins us this morning Dwayne how are you
I'm doing good I heard you're doing well
this morning that's just typical like do
you ever get bored making making jumpers
and never you don't oh no it's a sweet
video and style but that sound of the
net is awesome though right when it goes
in I mean it's just like is there a
better sound than that in sports then
the ball going through the net no no no
I said I mean people have different
interpretations and what it sounds like
but to me it's like and and I always
like when the net would get caught up on
the rim so then you just reinforce that
you made it you switched it hey you guys
get the net down I'm gonna go back down
the other end
did you play football in high school
I'll try to play I thought I was good
but I guess I wasn't wait I I heard you
were pretty good your high school was
pretty good at football
I did some research yeah and what
position did you play
well I have big hands and so I played
wide receiver and I played cornerback
but there everyone told me I thought I
was like the next company but everyone
told me that basketball was my sport so
I think I eventually listen if you
stayed with football could you play
college oh I don't know I mean my I
would say maybe a smaller schools as I
started late I play some ball to be a
great year and it took me a little while
but I don't think we'd be on this call
right now about what a stable Brian now
I got to see LeBron play one game in
high school in football yeah was it good
oh yeah he was he was he was Randy Moss
yeah he could have played
yeah if LeBron wanted to he could play
in the NFL well I think you think
there's a lot of yeah well I think a lot
of basketball players you know could
could you know be good at football now
is not the talent part of it is to
taking a hit part of it is what they
body go through part of it is the you
know is those things that are you know
are challenging if he say the leaves I
don't think it's you know it's a talent
thing at all and vice versa
a lot of football players aren't super
talented and could play on this course
as well
well maybe you couldn't play in college
but you could probably play for the
Bears right now doing it while bears are
struggling well bear this drunkenness
always said that always saying listen
just let me be a goal and receiver the
Reds on let me get in that door to the
corner never to the middle let me go
okay I think Russell Westbrook would be
an unbelievable football player I could
deep into back wide receiver he could
probably play both ways if he wanted to
yeah he's probably be one of those guys
then punt the ball kick field goals hey
throw the ball the touchdown run it you
didn't want to know God okay like
Kordell Stewart type Oh / yeah / okay if
if Russell Westbrook averages a
triple-double this year
can he win the int should he be the MVP
can you be more valuable to your team if
you averaged a triple-double well no and
this the thing is you know I think the
MVP has changed over the years you know
for what it they need to change the
letters because you know it's not always
the most viable player wins and
sometimes it's the best or there's team
but you got a lot of guys that are
viable to the team but they got good
teams without them they would be you
know one of the worst records in the
league he's one of those guys he's one
of those guys that you take him off the
team and I said that they have bad at
the pic players but he's the engine of
their team you know he does so much to
to give them confidence to even went to
be in games to win I'm sold right now
he's playing MVP level the most viable
player but you know you got other guys
with the best player on the best teams
it's hard to argue that with the way
that you know it has shifted to being
that Dwayne by the way joining us on
behalf of a PokerStars they've launched
a new razored campaign with Cristiano
Ronaldo
so you and Cristiano Ronaldo yeah yeah
man I have a good relationship with
Ronaldo and it's cool you know we both
able to do this campaign and it's just
it's fun you know it's just like a you
know raise the stakes type um you know
thing you can do I could do better so we
both had a father and I are part other
than this cool down and it's starting to
come out
could he teach you how to flop
definitely yeah cuz you know what I need
to learn the new era of floppy I had to
always did want a debug start all of
this uh you know what I can't say he
started but I mean I fresh in my mind I
remember him being very very good at it
and one of the first ones that I
remember you know being amazing and
sloppy and kind of what it was sloppy
did for him it just brought attention to
the referees eyes and it made them
called things that they didn't even
think that you know was they didn't know
what it was but he just made it look
like it was something he can they call
it they believed was because it looked
like some was happening and then Duke
must have been watching and then
everybody at Duke learned how to flop
they masters I think you can take a
class at Duke and flop England closely I
did you know I did what Shane back in
the day and I don't know I'm saying with
a farmer I know he took a lot of charges
but I don't know me clapping is a part
of of the world we live in in sports and
everything basketball get the bad title
for floppy but I see there's some awful
flops by the way and I just got more
shocking a full recently I make feel
like a flower but when I looked at the
video but in a moment I thought I got
hit and I didn't know it was coming but
I looked at video so yes that's for sure
wish I could the fool at what point did
you like that the Michael Jordan
phenomenon when you're in Chicago
growing up at what point did you
understand exactly who he was and would
you ever think in your wildest dreams
you would play in the NBA
well I mean I'll talk about this Alton
especially called my Chicago I fell in
love with the game of basketball nine
years old and it was watching you know
Jordan in the pool
when their first championship that's
what I really fell in love with that's
what I really knew that's what I wanted
to do and I remember sitting on the
floor looking at the TV on the floor and
I health and that's what I want to be
you know that's the feeling I want and I
felt so much pride you know business
Chicago when they won a championship and
I wanted that feeling so you know that I
would think it was a possibility I
didn't know you know law came from I
didn't see too many people you know
making it out the way you know that
vision but you know crazy things that
happen in life and I kept my dreams and
my hopes alive and I'm 14 years later
I've been living and living this dream I
don't know if anybody else thought this
but when you and LeBron Chris Paul Melo
you're at the ESPYs and when you guys
started the ESPYs and when you were done
with that I I thought of Muhammad Ali
and Muhammad Ali dying and what kind of
impact he may have had on younger
athletes like yourself or Colin
Kaepernick or LeBron is that too much of
a stretch because I don't I don't know
if Muhammad Ali dying and you got to see
what he was and who he was what he stood
for had any impact on you whatsoever so
I I throw that out did it well I think
it's an impact on everyone and you know
it is it's at some time it takes you
know certain things that happen for
people to be really appreciated for what
they do or have done and I think you
know him passing you know they're you
know if you notice all out leaves and a
lot of people around the world was you
know putting out these messages about
what he meant to them and I think it
just opened eyes again for us in a
moment it just felt like you know we
needed to use our voice you know we
thought we had the right platform coming
up and you know a lot of these guys who
always out there you know telling people
a I do this support this or buy this or
you know and I thought oh I thought we
all thought it was time to use our voice
for for bigger calls and a greater good
and you know it was great that we had
the platform to do it you know a lot of
people have things they want to do it's
a they don't have the same platform as
we have so we were speaking for you know
thousands of millions of others probably
that have the same goal before I let you
go Thanksgiving dinner with
Derrick Rose and Carmelo at Melos crib
is that right yeah now what did you
bring what did you bring
well well for the easy thing to bring is
alcohol bring wine so my wife my wife
make sure you know about six to eight
bottles of different kind of alcohol to
bring over and that's always the easy
gift but Melo and Lala for the last few
years because lives in New York year
before Thanksgiving they allowed us it
took coming you know they're like family
to us and it was great so it's got a
chance to be there with DeRose and he
had nowhere to go deeper so you know
they just opened the doors people have
nowhere to go on Thanksgiving it was
great we had a great time great
conversation but amazing food you know
if you pass a dish to Carmelo you don't
get it back a little funny you know the
ball stops with melon my guy we talk a
lot of my guys
PokerStars and their raise it campaign
its hashtag raise it and you can see the
raise it videos with Dwyane Wade and
Cristiano Ronaldo great to talk to you
again and congrats on the season so far
Thank You Dwayne dad thank you as always
to keep making those baskets man I will
I will thank you that's a Dwyane Wade
one great shooter to another the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience